we got our hands on the call of duty
vanguard beta build a little early so
i'm here to tell you what's new and if
it's worth checking out when the beta
goes public later this month our goal
here is to have a little fun talk about
the new call of duty and genuinely
figure out which audience vanguard is
for by breaking down what we were able
to see
of course our experiences with this
closed beta may differ from what the
public beta will offer maps modes and
weapons are still being tweaked so just
keep that in mind as we continue if you
enjoy this breakdown stay tuned by
subscribing to gamespot for continued
coverage of call of duty battlefield
halo and more let's get into it
as we were waiting for the lobbies to
build up we were able to see newly added
game modes weapons perks attachments and
way more let's begin with the gunsmith
it's back and it's nearly identical to
the one featured in warzone and modern
warfare 2019
like before as you level up your weapon
categories for unlockables begin to
build up such as scopes stocks and
barrels i was able to peek at an stg44
blueprint and confirmed that all assault
rifles can have up to 10 attachments the
blueprint that they featured didn't even
have them all filled out while we're on
the topic the attachments in general
were plentiful that's probably because
you can now rank your weapons up to
level 70.
my jaw dropped looking at the amount of
scopes alone the variety here is
honestly commendable but it's similar to
modern warfare 2019 where you can
actually build a bad gun if you wanted
to and i really dig that but remember in
call of duty world at war or even world
war ii where there were just a few
fictional scopes that were sort of
tacked on in vanguard that dial is
turned up to 11. it looks like for the
sake of fun gunplay reality is taking a
backseat and i think this will prevent
these classic world war ii weapons from
feeling stale all of this is also
probably in preparation for the eventual
merge with war zone you can even unlock
alternate iron sights which is cool or
replace your iron sights with this film
projector
just kidding it's an infrared scope what
the beta also had nearly every weapon
unlocked if you've ever played a world
war ii game you'll be familiar with the
offerings the mp40 thompson the bar and
the combat knife using these longer
range rifles like ars snipers and lmgs
on these bigger maps felt like
stretching their legs it felt good to
use them at long ranges compared to the
smaller maps on champion hill
speaking of which the maps we did play
on were pretty different from each other
and they played well in most game modes
we tried there was a pretty big snowy
city map that took place in a town
square
a really green beach side map a hotel
map with roof access that was pretty
cool and there was a mountaintop map
that was called eagle's nest that mostly
took place indoors these maps featured
more destructible cover just like the
alpha and in my experience i found it to
be helpful in some situations to peak or
take a second to reload instead of
running for cover every time i needed to
some form of broken cover made it a
little easier to hide for a second and
then jump right back into a gunfight
which kept the pacing pretty brisk i
wouldn't say these maps are porous like
modern warfare 2019's where there's a
lot of places to hide and camp however
what i enjoyed and what kept it separate
from modern warfare 2019 was that you
were able to break these small forms of
cover entirely if they were being
overused
so in my experience it didn't really get
campy especially in blitz mode
speaking of blitz mode we tested out the
combat pacing for certain game modes
there were three
tactical which hosts smaller 6v6 matches
assault which is anywhere from 20 to 28
players and blitz mode which can host up
to 48 players and 24 v24
blitz mode was actually pretty crazy i
wasn't expecting the combat pacings to
be so different from each other but
blitz mode actually was
it felt like ground war except on maps
that weren't designed for ground war it
was definitely a highlight for me we
played other modes like team deathmatch
domination kill confirmed like i
mentioned and patrol which is their
hardpoint mode where the hardpoint is
continually moving and that mode was
pretty fun i wouldn't say any of these
game modes were new and exciting but
classic a good way to just test
everything out all of these maps and
modes that we played have been confirmed
by sledgehammer to be in the open beta
as well as the return of champion hill
perks kill streaks and field upgrades
are back and most of them are familiar
if you've played a call of duty game in
the last few years
i am sad to report that dogs are back
please stop making me kill dogs in games
some issues with the alpha build have
been addressed with the beta when you're
wounded and on the brink of death your
screen doesn't dim so harshly as it did
before
lighting has also been tweaked and in my
opinion it was easier to see enemies
more issues did pop up through our
playthrough but nothing game breaking
there are small graphical glitches like
this shoulder one some server issues and
most agreed that the volume overall was
kind of low also in our play test on
console there was no sign of the fov
slider
on a more personal note i didn't have
much luck with the shotgun class
up close in a firefight i lost to an
stg44
at point blank
i know this person had shots on me and
killed me first but i think the shot i
landed should have killed them too what
do you think
[Music]
another gripe for me might be the
goliath which is a remote controlled
kill streak it's pretty funny to use
this thing and like run people over with
it and detonate it but it has trouble
driving over terrain and gets caught on
a lot of stuff even dead bodies which
was pretty funny
we got eyes there was also that beach
map that i mentioned which looks really
nice but it's easy to get pinned down in
your spawn especially when you're
playing something like domination
specifically blitz domination
oh wow i guess he felt the same way but
aside from these smaller issues we
encountered i can personally say i had
fun and when i reflect on this beta i
think of the maps blitz mode and how the
guns we've seen for years actually felt
kind of different and fun
the beta build gave me the real
multiplayer test i wanted and while all
of this may change after the call of
duty honeymoon phase in a few months i
can safely say that i enjoyed my time
with the build as is right now despite
being yet another world war ii shooter
vanguard's multiplayer felt like it had
fans of newer call of duty games in mind
especially in terms of the user
interface and weapons perks and field
upgrades all of that just reminds me of
modern warfare 2019 but at least in my
playthrough it feels like they left some
of those problems behind such as super
porous map design which leads to slower
paced gun fights in vanguard things felt
more hectic and gunfights were
constantly happening especially in the
blitz mode as i mentioned
if you're excited to try out this beta
build let me know in the comments but
also let me know if this isn't the kind
of call of duty you're interested in
we've got way more vanguard coverage
coming up so stay tuned to gamespot for
more videos like this coming soon
okay i'll then on some gameplay here
that i thought was pretty funny we were
playing patrol which is that moving
hardpoint mode and we were doing well
until who is immortal dropped a glide
bomb on our entire team take a look
[Music]
hope you enjoyed that i couldn't help
but laugh i'll see you next time
you